okay so this videos wouldn't be the
fourth game itachi a little bit
different it starts with sorts of
sequence of thrust to anyway
people start doing a slight distance and
it also has the unusual feature that the
thing that gets off the line rather than
holds the line okay so if I scroll back
I opened the slide the he thrust
straight down the line I move off line
from here so badly for number fiendish
side if you do close up open up slightly
each for us that's a quick finish there
you know the whole thing he had to pull
up really short so he did it he started
from seeing her to stop then close it -
there's nothing wrong with my battery so
we're stop start D so by taking this
distance you give him the opportunity to
do full thrust for me to do for us and
that's kind of beneficial for training
building any body movements okay
hey Rach you brings down any trouble to
be the rock you keep my soul under roll
these hits a rock you can't variation
basically always second for the
variation
okay so that's the wolf kill Itachi and
his variations have you learn something
[Music]